[موسيقى]
الهند دوله مجاوره نحن جيران ولنتحدث
بصراحه حتى وان كانت هذه الجيره ليست
باختيارنا فانها ستبقى الى الابد وعلينا
الاختيار بين العيش بسلام والازدهار او
المخاصمه وهجر الوقت والموارد علينا اتخاذ
القرار لقد تعلمت باكستان الدرس لقد خضنا
ثلاث حروب مع الهند وعواقب تلك الحروب او
نتائجها كانت فقط المزيد من البؤس
والبطاله والفقر
والملايين وهبطوا الى مستويات الادنى
لقد تعلمنا الدرس ونود ان نعيش بسلام مع
الهند بشرط حل مشكله الاساسيه وهذه مساله
مهمه جدا
رساله الى القياده الهنديه ورئيس الوزراء
مودي هي لنجلس والله خذ محادثات جده
وصادقه لحل مسائلنا الملحه مثل كشمير التي
تشهد انتهاكات صارخه لحقوق الانسان في كل
يوم
كيف احتفظوا بكل اشكال الاستقلال التي
منحوها للكشميريين حسب الماده 270 من
الدستور التي قاموا بالغائها في عام 2019
[موسيقى]